[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález octavo día
desde el inicio de la invasión de rusia
al territorio keniano una jornada en la
que en una segunda mesa de diálogo entre
las partes involucradas en esta guerra
acordaron la creación de corredores
humanitarios para civiles ambos bandos
decretaron también un alto el fuego
mientras estos corredores son
establecidos importante destacar el
anuncio hecho por moldavia que es un
país vecino a ucrania que ha recibido
también a miles de desplazados en
solamente una semana y que cuenta con
una región separatista prorrusa es decir
un escenario muy parecido como el que
tenía ucrania hace algunas semanas atrás
anunció hace pocas horas que se
incorporará a la unión europea tal vez
previendo un poco lo que le puede llegar
a suceder viendo a lo que le pasa a su
vecino ucrania eso en cuanto a los
hechos del día pero desde mucho
tiempo atrás antes del inicio de esta
guerra abierta el discurso del kremlin
ha tocado fibras sensibles de la
historia rusa para justificar esta
invasión al territorio
llamada en rusia simplemente como una
operación militar especial así se les
llaman rusia a esta invasión al
territorio ucraniano así lo decía el
presidente ruso vladimir putin hace
exactamente una semana horas antes de
empezar la invasión
he decidido llevar a cabo una operación
militar especial
cuyo objetivo es proteger a las personas
que han sido intimidadas y sometidas al
genocidio por el régimen de jeff durante
ocho años
y
nos esforzamos por la desmilitarización
y la desnazificación de ucrania y
llevaremos ante la justicia a quienes
cometieron múltiples crímenes
sangrientos contra civiles incluidos
ciudadanos rusos e
incinerados desde esa óptica desde esa
óptica del presidente putin vendió la
idea de ir a liberar a ucrania
desmilitarizar la también
desnazificación después de hablar de
genocidio después de haber criticado a
las autoridades ucranianas todo esto sin
ninguna prueba concreta o evidente por
lo menos el presidente no lo mostró ni a
rusia ni al resto del mundo pero con el
deseo claro de evitar que kiev optará
por unirse a la otan ya la unión europea
en respuesta el discurso ucraniano ha
sido de un llamado a la unidad a la
necesidad de combatir a ese invasor y
también estar al nivel de igual a igual
con los integrantes de la unión europea
a quienes pidió ayuda veamos
ok
mujer está muy bien
sin ustedes ucrania estará sola hemos
demostrado nuestra fuerza hemos
demostrado al menos que somos como
ustedes
así que demuestran ustedes que están con
nosotros demuestran que no nos abandonan
y que son realmente europeos así la vida
vencerá a la muerte y la luz vencerá a
las tinieblas gloria a ucrania
muchos han indicado que el discurso
oficial ucraniano el manejo de la
información de los contenidos que
distribuye y también el manejo que le ha
dado a las redes sociales
también las circunstancias que están
viviendo en estos momentos han permitido
haber catapultado al presidente
ucraniano volodymyr selenski al nivel de
un héroe nacional también muy respetado
y admirado en occidente y en otros
países alrededor del mundo que tanto hay
de cierto en lo que leemos en los medios
ucranianos y en los medios rusos y en el
discurso oficial que da ucrania que da
el kremlin que da la unión europea y que
da eeuu que tanto ha servido el discurso
de genocidios hechos históricos como la
invasión de los nazis a ucrania para
llevar a cabo esta guerra que tanto de
él
ya sea desde el lado ruso o desde el
lado ucraniano también desde el lado de
la unión europea o de eeuu han comprado
las naciones occidentales la guerra
mediática en el marco de la guerra de
ucrania es nuestro tema de debate hoy en
france 24 y para analizar este tema
hemos invitado a sonia herrera sánchez
es el doctor en comunicación audiovisual
y especialista en estudios feministas y
periodismo de paz también está con
nosotros javier bernabé fraguas él es
doctor en relaciones internacionales
también especialista en información y
comunicación internacional y en
comunicación de crisis y conflicto
ustedes nuestros televidentes también
pueden participar en el debate con sus
comentarios y sus preguntas lo pueden
hacer a través de nuestras redes
sociales no se encuentran en facebook en
instagram y en twitter estamos como
arroba france24 guión bajo s arroba
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal es
el recuerdo que nuestra etiqueta es
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos todos
los comentarios y las preguntas a través
de nuestras redes sociales comienzo
entonces con sonia en la ciudad de
barcelona en españa preguntándole
la fuerte influencia del discurso para
persuadir y para construir una retórica
de guerra digámoslo así para justificar
la invasión y los hechos que estamos
viendo en los últimos días allí en el
este de europa como lo ve usted
muchas gracias santiago es un placer
estar con vosotros aunque en estas
circunstancias se suele decir no hay una
frase hecha que suele decir que lo
primero que muere en una guerra es la
verdad y lo constatamos una vez más que
con este episodio
tanto por el lado ruso en las imágenes
que
estábamos viendo eran buena buena prueba
de ello y vladimir putin y el kremlin
está mostrando pues una guerra
una guerra muy limpia que he leído
alguna alguna compañera hoy en prensa no
una guerra muy limpia sin muertos donde
solo se ve el ejército ruso como si
fuera prácticamente de paseo y por otro
lado no desde desde los medios
ucranianos que se muestra todo lo
contrario no intentando fomentar la
empatía en pues en todos aquellos
territorios o países de de la unión
europea que se puedan o de occidente sí
sí encontramos también a eeuu donde
donde te lens que pueda pensar que que
tiene aliados
claro esto esto es así no se desactiva
una maquinaria donde donde el periodismo
queda a un lado
específicamente el periodismo de paz o
el periodismo preventivo sí y se pone en
marcha la maquinaria de propaganda
y javier en estas circunstancias en este
escenario en el que estamos o que están
viviendo en el este de europa y que vive
el mundo entero también que tan
importante es en el desarrollo de las
guerras de los conflictos en el discurso
de ambas partes de los que estén
implicados o de los que estén
interesados en este tipo de
enfrentamientos en este caso estaríamos
hablando de rusia ucrania la unión
europea y eeuu que tanto peso tiene el
discurso en este tipo de conflictos
armados
el discurso ha tenido peso al inicio
bajo mi punto de vista
si vemos el enfoque hacia el exterior el
discurso va a seguir teniendo peso hacia
el interior de lo que estamos hablando
es decir creo que hacia eeuu de hacerla
en europea
el discurso de putin no creo que tenga
ningún peso a nivel propagandístico la
propaganda rusa se está trabajando hacia
el interior del país yo he estado
intentando hablar con
alumnos y exalumnos rusos porque en mi
universidad hay un convenio para cursar
uno de los másteres que tenemos con una
universidad rusa y evidentemente me
atrevo a deciros desde aquí en y en
directo que el miedo es tajante y lo ves
en respuestas de colegas que normalmente
no responderían como están respondiendo
es decir
dentro de rusia ese discurso puede tener
un peso pero hay mucha gente que
evidentemente no se lo está creyendo
cuando hablamos de desnazificación se en
un país
donde el presidente es judío donde ha
salido una superviviente del cerco nazi
a kiev que no me atrevo a decirte la
edad porque ha salido hoy en medios
entre 80 y 90 años en una comunidad
judía diciendo que qué está haciendo
putin evidentemente creo que bueno pues
el trabajo de las palabras tienen un
peso pero el trabajo de los hechos creo
que está siendo demoledor en este caso
sí también por supuesto que la
propaganda es fundamental pero claro
insisto que alguien en el caso ruso bajo
mi punto de vista está mucho más
enfocada hacia el interior porque hacia
el exterior no creo que haya nada donde
rascar en este momento javier sonia
quiero que hablemos de algunos de los
términos que han venido utilizando
medios rusos han citado también medios
occidentales porque han sido palabras
textuales del presidente putin del
canciller
y de algunos funcionarios rusos vamos a
comenzar primero por el lado del
discurso ruso ya javier lo mencionaba la
desnazificación de ucrania
desmilitarización de ucrania se habló de
un genocidio contra los ciudadanos rusos
en el este del país para construir este
discurso que lo que estamos viendo es
que no es un discurso nuevo de las
últimas semanas putin ya llevaba muchos
meses lanzando mensajes
dando los luces de lo que podíamos
llegar a enfrentar que lo que estamos
viendo en este momento son ya cuál es su
análisis de estos términos el término de
clasificación ha dado la vuelta al mundo
porque la gente no entiende en el
contexto en el que está el mundo ahora
que se hable de nazismo en ucrania
el otro día habrá una compañera
comentaba también que seguramente se
invadiera en españa también habría pues
grupos neonazis seguramente luchando y
defendiendo y defendiendo el país y que
no por eso se consideraría que españa es
necesario desclasificar la no a pesar de
del crecimiento de la ultraderecha en
los últimos años es evidente como
cualquier javier que es un discurso y
una justificación hacia adentro hoy
salían imágenes incluso de de soldados
rusos super jóvenes
desolados y
desmoronándose al hablar con sus madres
y con sus familias por teléfono diciendo
es que lo que nos estamos encontrando es
una una guerra de verdad y una
resistencia que no esperábamos porque se
nos había dicho esto no que íbamos a
liberar al pueblo ucraniano de un
régimen totalitario y no está siendo así
entonces bueno es probable
que está fagocitando de ciertos términos
acabe cayendo por su propio peso o al
menos así lo espero javier para los
rusos dada la historia que tienen qué
peso tiene este tipo de palabras
genocidios desnazificación
desmilitarización confrontación
entendemos el protagonismo que tuvo la
unión soviética en el marco de la
segunda guerra mundial la relación que
tiene con ucrania a lo largo de la
historia y episodios muy difíciles que
vivieron los ucranianos al interior de
la unión soviética hambrunas también el
acecho de los nazis a ciudades como
leningrado son palabras que
históricamente a los rusos les genera un
peso muy grande a nivel de su conciencia
de su historia y de su pasado como
nación como lo ve usted
claro por eso se utilizan por eso por
eso le doy un putting las pone en marcha
ping para tocar y algunas teclas algunos
clics de alguna población rusa que pueda
estar bastante desinformado la cuestión
es cuándo tienes rusos que están
informados que controlan lo que pasa en
el mundo que saben lo que pasa a su
alrededor y que esas palabras no pueden
calar de una manera definitiva es decir
yo creo que van a tener un peso
importante hasta determinado momento y a
mí lo que me da bastante respeto lo que
me da miedo es que va a pasar en el
siguiente paso de este enfrentamiento
que bajo mi punto de vista después de
los ataques artilleros monumentales que
estamos viendo puede convertirse en una
guerra de cerco prácticamente medieval
una guerra de asedio donde puede haber
cierta resistencia barrio por barrio o
calle por calle donde tropas de
operaciones especiales tengan que hacer
un trabajo
exhaustivo de limpieza prácticamente
cuerpo a cuerpo en ese escenario donde
van a quedar los medios de comunicación
que tenemos allí porque evidentemente
creo que creo internet va a quedar en
manos del invasor en cuanto tenga mucho
más poder del territorio y en ese
momento es una pregunta que hago porque
porque tengo inmensas dudas donde van a
poder informar los medios de
comunicación que diversos países tenemos
allí donde nuestros enviados especiales
si van a poder hacer su trabajo se les
va a dejar porque esa para mí va a ser
el elemento contra lenguaje más
importante el elemento de las imágenes y
del lenguaje que se genere a partir de
medios de comunicación que no
pertenezcan ni a ucrania ni a rusia si
la pongo en la mesa porque no tengo ni
idea buena pregunta
y en el marco de ese siguiente paso que
podríamos llegar a evidenciar en traigo
aquí una frase que de hecho la ha
pronunciado hoy el presidente putin ha
dicho que ucrania y rusia son un solo
pueblo yo no sé qué significado pueda
tener para ustedes esta frase pero
viendo que occidente no leyó las frases
que dio el presidente putin a lo largo
de estos meses para entender la
estrategia
sonia esto que nos puede que nos puede
estar diciendo haciendo un poco de
análisis de esta frase
podríamos estar tal vez especulando que
está haciendo referencia a ese gran
pasado histórico a esos siglos de unión
que tiene rusia con ucrania o a un
posible control de ucrania
no me gusta hacer política ficción no
porque siempre es arriesgado pero creo
que putin ha dejado claro no sólo en
esta semana sino en
el personaje no es nuevo también que a
esta falsa sorpresa que
genera no como si ahora descubriera
descubriéramos todos de repente las
ambiciones de de de vladimir putin
también resulta incluso un poco naif
pero creo que la ambición expansionista
o
imperialista de de putin se ha dejado
ver en sus discursos desde hace
muchísimos años no está
esta alusión constante no ha pasado pues
podríamos decir que así la ciudad de
rusia ha estado siempre muy presente
allá y no también está este apelar pues
bueno a los orígenes y desde el pueblo
ruso no vinculados a ucrania y bueno y
también de ahí pues surgen esos temores
que tú que tú compartidas al principio
del programa pues de moldavia y de otros
países vecinos de antiguas repúblicas
soviéticas
quiero que pasemos al otro lado de la
frontera digámoslo hacia la otra cara de
la moneda y es el discurso desde kiev
desde ucrania han construido un discurso
a través de los medios de comunicación
un uso muy distinto al que la o moscú a
las redes sociales y a la forma de
entregar información y esto ha provocado
una gran unión de los ucranianos que es
un país étnicamente diverso con unas
variantes culturales muy particulares y
que precisamente esa construcción de
nación ha costado pero para enfrentarse
a los rusos si ha habido unidad y
también prácticamente ha lanzado al
presidente selenski como un héroe
nacional y como un personaje destacado a
nivel internacional ahora resultó que ya
no lo ven como un simple actor que llegó
a la presidencia del país sino que lo
ven como un político con las botas
puestas luchando por su país dando
ejemplo de liderazgo como ven ustedes
esa creación de ese discurso que también
los medios occidentales tenemos que
agarrar con las pinzas porque no todo lo
que estén diciendo desde kiev
pueda que sea con un mensaje muy
positivo para entregar a los medios de
comunicación todo toca pasarlo por un
dado al cheque
charlé lo que no sabía era del arte toca
pasarlo por un double set pero quiero
decir
que queremos desde el esquí
porque si ahora mismo se le acusa de no
ser un gran presidente por haberse
quedado en ucrania en vez de haber huido
del país que hubiéramos pensado si
hubiera huido del país es decir yo
entiendo lo que estás diciendo a partir
de un discurso propagandístico ucraniano
que es absolutamente cierto y que por
otro lado es previsible y lógico pero
es que no sé no sé
qué ha podido cambiar para que
entendamos que esa persona está haciendo
lo que debe hacer que es quedarse a
defender su país es decir más allá de
que si no están ucrania y lo que estamos
viviendo es un montaje de celestes y que
está haciendo ese trabajo fuera del país
que el resto es sí sí se ha quedado
dentro es cierto no evidentemente son
mensajes propagandísticas evidentemente
las imágenes que justamente ahora
estamos viendo de ese aplauso unánime en
el parlamento europeo no dejar terminar
el aplauso levantarse puño en alto e
irse está trabajado y son imágenes
poderosas pero es que no creo que
podamos esperar otra cosa en un momento
en el que están invadiendo tu país
discurso finalmente es convencer a la
gente y este discurso puede que no esté
a favor o en contra ha logrado convencer
a los ucranianos los ha unido ha
convencido al mundo entero y el respaldo
a ucrania es a nivel mundial cosa que no
ha recibido el discurso desde el kremlin
por ejemplo pero es que no veo
alternativa
causa que debería haber hecho selenski
para no ser propagandístico entonces
nuestro en este punto quiero decir no no
veo opción así pero en términos en
términos de la estrategia comunicativa y
del discurso qué análisis hace usted que
destaca el manejo de las redes estos
mensajes cortos del presidente
hablándole casi que detuvo actual dos
ucranianos o cualquier este que es la
estrategia que ha dado resultado yo creo
que es la sumatoria y la imagen de un
presidente mucho más cercano que
cualquier otro anterior el presidente de
ucrania al pueblo más allá de la
anécdota de que haya sido un cómico y un
actor bueno tenemos otro otro actor que
no fue cómico desde luego desde luego no
lo fue para américa latina que es una
amiga en verdad en eeuu
la figura del esquí yo creo que desde
fuera de ucrania estaba siendo
interpretada de una manera y desde
dentro de ucrania estaba siendo
interpretada de otra no me atrevo a
decir si tú también por conversaciones
con colegas ucranianos claro diciendo
bueno que
no lo estaba haciendo tan mal años se
podría pensar así pues para complementar
antes darle la palabra a sonia la
revista forbes hizo un artículo
precisamente hablando sobre esta
creación de discurso por parte de
ucrania y le hacía una lista de una
serie de elecciones de liderazgo que
estaba dando el presidente selenski al
mundo entero y era casi 10 ítems
diferentes en los que destacaban muchas
de las cualidades de lo que había hecho
por lo menos en la última semana sonia
su opinión sobre este discurso de
ucrania sobre la estrategia que ha hecho
el gobierno ucraniano para difundir
información hacia el resto del mundo y
unir al pueblo
yo creo que hay un uso muy
inteligente de la imagen del propio
presidente que no es que está inventando
el hilo negro él por su parte no creo
que a mí me vi a mi el verlo aparecer no
en camiseta con indumentaria militar
como muy de traje de faena
de me he quedado a defender mi país no y
por lo tanto esto no lo puedo hacer de
traje y corbata a mí me me traía a la
memoria no a aquellas imágenes de barack
obama
desplazándose
a zonas de alguna catástrofe natural y
bajarse de del helicóptero presidencial
con la camisa arremangada como como de
yo vengo aquí ayudar aunque fuera aunque
fuera un acto puramente político y de y
de presencia o sea esas son esas
estrategias de la comunicación política
que se llevan trabajando muchísimo
tiempo en el que como decía javier pues
hace que el presidente se presente como
una persona mucho más cercana al pueblo
no como una masa de [__] son y dentro
de esa estrategia de comunicación
política que es tan necesaria es
precisamente la construcción de héroes
en este tipo de conflictos pensaría yo
que esto es más importante para la
población que para los mismos
gobernantes y cómo lo vio usted en el
escenario en el que estamos
que es mejor o que puede funcionar mejor
un hombre fuerte como putin o un héroe
líder como selenski
yo creo que que ambos arquetipos
son arquetipos muy patriarcales no a fin
de cuentas se nos
acaba pareciendo que la guerra se juega
entre entre dos personas y por otro lado
pues está invisibilizando en todas las
estrategias de
resistencia también pacífica que puedan
haber de un lado y de otro no son
escasas las imágenes ya mí me parecen
quizás de lo más potentes que ha
aparecido estos días en medios son las
manifestaciones contra la guerra en
territorio ruso que esa gente sí que
está poniendo el cuerpo no para parar la
guerra y asumiendo grandes riesgos
entonces bueno esto tiene que ver mucho
con con un tipo de periodismo que que ha
crecido muchísimo en los últimos años
que es el periodismo de declaraciones y
al final en este conflicto bélico
también se está se está asumiendo este
tipo de relato no de putin dijo de
lenski dijo no
y entremedio se invisibiliza las
víctimas si entro ya en la recta final
del programa javier
pregunta importante creo que la pregunta
más
destacada de este programa es en el
escenario en el que estamos en esta
invasión de rusia el territorio
ucraniano cómo se puede construir un
periodismo
que tenga un discurso mediático que le
apueste a la paz porque todo lo que
hemos oído es guerra hablamos de putin
argumentando su
necesidad de invadir ucrania y hacerles
que su necesidad de tenerse que defender
y a llamar a los ucranianos a armarse y
defender pero no hay un discurso de paz
de ninguno de los lados ni siquiera de
la unión europea o de eeuu que todavía
apoyan la idea de una salida diplomática
es una pregunta que la comparto con
ustedes porque surgió en una
conversación con una de mis colegas aquí
en la redacción más romeros que es parte
del equipo de france 24
me quedo sin respuesta no pudimos
concluir ningún tipo de eje de respuesta
para esta pregunta y quiero hacerla y
trasladárselo a ustedes a ver qué
piensan
bueno es que yo no sé si
sonia te va a poder aportar algo más
pero por mi parte te vas a quedar sin
respuesta también
y te lo digo desde un trabajo bastante
exhaustivo habiendo habiendo sido pues
lo que diseñó el término académico de
periodismo preventivo y habiendo
trabajado en él desde hace muchísimos
años y habiendo estudiado a galtung y
con galtung y
creo que es absolutamente inviable en
este momento
de que los medios de comunicación pueden
hacer algo parecido a todas las
directrices de periodismo de paz lo
primero porque estamos viendo un
una lucha absolutamente desequilibrada
y por lo tanto ante la invasión de un
territorio con la fuerza aplastante que
lo está haciendo rusia es
el elemento de equilibrio bajo mi punto
de vista estaría en enfocar
reportajes a las víctimas del conflicto
de una y otra parte que se está haciendo
en parte bajo mi punto de vista porque
evidentemente la cifra es abrumadora en
una semana un millón de refugiados y los
que nos quedan en las semanas siguientes
ante eso no se puede ocultar en los
medios españoles por ejemplo bueno pues
hay destacados hay venegas destacados
periodistas destacadas cubriendo peso
específicamente por ejemplo en la
frontera de ucrania y polonia si esto es
una vía
seres de rusia bajo el punto de vista es
imposible
porque los medios están totalmente
encorsetados hay una censura tremenda
que te vamos a dar y es de lo más claro
lo que estaba diciendo son ya no de las
víctimas en muchos casos mujeres además
que han sido detenidas apaleadas en la
calle por manifestarse contra putin
los medios tienen que cubrir eso pero
qué medios están en rusia con la
posibilidad de cubrir eso claro javier y
sonia a su opinión
y coincido con javier en que en rusia
ahora mismo es imposible de hecho los
pocos medios creo que todavía
quedaban un poco independientes y que
cuestionaron el conflicto y que
pronunciaron creo la palabra guerra y
fueron censurados al primer o segundo
día de la invasión rusa y tampoco creo
que se lo podamos pedir ni siquiera a
los medios ucranianos no pero que sí que
cree ni a los compañeros y compañeras
que están cubriendo de otras
nacionalidades que están cubriendo el
conflicto en primera línea creo que hay
que es difícil hacer periodismo de paz
desde desde el frente no y por hace poco
más que contar lo que se está viviendo
pero creo que sí sin lugar a dudas si lo
podemos pedir a quienes trabajan y
trabajamos desde la retaguardia en otros
países a las voces expertas que se lleva
a opinar a las tertulias como nosotros y
como otras muchas personas porque creo
que lo que no se puede hacer desde esos
espacios cómodos y confortables es
todavía más el juego sí y creo que sí
que es momento quizás y sobre todo ante
ante la amenaza nuclear que el
presidente putin ha puesto ha puesto
sobre la mesa pues sí que hay que abogar
porque el periodismo de pases es una
salida
estos días está criticando mucho y en
redes está haciendo está viendo ataques
muy violentos y es muy paradójico pero
está viendo que es violencia contra
contra el movimiento pacifista y se nos
tacha pues eso no de ilusos de nadie de
correa la importancia lo que está
sucediendo al conflicto que se está
viviendo allí en minuto a minuto ya me
quedan pocos minutos para terminar el
programa quiero terminar hablando del
tema de las críticas a los medios rusos
los medios internacionales de la
federación de rusia desplegados en eeuu
en europa y en américa latina para
informar desde la perspectiva de moscú
que han sido en algunos países
censurados es la censura la forma la
mejor forma que tiene occidente para
hacer frente a esta maquinaria de
propaganda del gobierno ruso a través de
sus canales de noticias de sus agencias
de noticias y jesús
de sitios en internet es la mejor forma
para combatir esta desinformación de la
cual tanto critican al gobierno ruso de
estar contando la historia como no es
desde la perspectiva de occidente claro
está sonia
yo no creo que la censura nunca sea la
solución o sea me parece comprensible
pero pero bueno aquí sí m
creo que era de unamuno no aquella frase
de venceréis pero no convenceréis no
pues creo que al final la censura
siempre es una resolución
simplista de
porque siempre cuesta muchísimo más
vencer y convencer mediante argumentos
que contrarresten ese discurso
propagandístico de los medios rusos es
más complejo pero creo que el camino va
por ahí bueno y cuando también muchos
medios occidentales han sido criticados
por llevar una perspectiva también muy
sesgada de esa realidad que se está
abriendo en ucrania javier su opinión
sobre este tema de la censura en
occidente
yo creo que la censura entre entre otras
cosas nos está dificultando el trabajo a
los que trabajamos analizando lo que lo
que hacen los medios yo soy periodista
también
y por lo tanto aquí se va a cortar en
europeas y no se ha cortado ya la
posibilidad de acceder a una sede de iu
a la agencia sputnik no
yo habiendo dicho esto no creo que sea
tampoco
equilibrado el decir que los medios
occidentales también están haciendo el
mismo tipo de propaganda por supuesto
que si están haciendo un trabajo dentro
de un conflicto armado de mensaje
propagandístico pero desde luego cuando
hablas de desnazificación cuando hablas
de genocidio del pueblo ruso en ucrania
y cuando hablas de cosas
que son completamente comprobables que
no han ocurrido
estoy con sonia es muy costoso hacer un
trabajo de
desmentir cada cosa que sale en esos
medios pero sería lo más correcto la
censura bajo el punto de vista nunca va
a ser un elemento
útil correcto ni ni ni ético a nivel de
trabajo profesional de los medios de
comunicación como creen entonces ustedes
que se puede hacer ese balance para
evitar la censura y para evitar
estos medios de propaganda de ambos
lados porque lo estamos viendo tanto de
occidente como rusia como desde el lado
ucraniano sonia
bueno mi
maestro xavi giro siempre ha hablado de
las grietas informativas y eso nos
enseñó
a muchos que que pasamos por por sus
clases en la universidad autónoma de
barcelona entonces creo que que siempre
y grietas y más aún en en un conflicto
no no está no está todo controlado y
entonces creo que es importante no
también ver qué alianzas
se pueden encontrar incluso dentro del
propio territorio ruso javier mismo que
lo contaba que él se había puesto en
contacto con exalumnos que siempre hay
voces críticas y es importante que esas
voces críticas se oigan también en los
medios occidentales claro javier
rápidamente para terminar el programa
por favor muy puntual
la cuestión sería que esas grietas
que el maestro mi amigo el maestro
xavier pero
destacó en muchos de sus análisis las
podemos encontrar en muchísimos medios
de comunicación es decir los medios de
comunicación que estás diciendo no son
un bloque monolítico esas dietas las
vamos a poder encontrar en programas de
la bbc esa dieta las vamos a poder
encontrar en programas de esta cadena en
la que estamos como no
va a depender del trabajo periodístico
que en muchos casos
depende de una iniciativa personal del
periodista o de la periodista que cubra
esa noticia si el elemento de como
decirte la prueba clave cuánta gente se
están utilizando cuáles son esas fuentes
si esas fuentes están contrastadas ahí
vamos a ver una grieta si esas fuentes
son monolíticas aquí no hay grieta
alguna si entonces es ese contraste lo
vamos a poder medir la cuestión es que
claro es muy difícil hacer hacer ese
trabajo pero es el momento de hacerlo
claro la javier y sonia les agradezco
mucho por haber estado con nosotros en
el debate haber compartido con nosotros
sus opiniones y a ustedes muchas gracias
por la sintonía sigan con france24
[Música]